- All right, gentlemen, up next
is our weapons test.
Up first, the kill test.
BRAD: I think my sword
is a lot prettier
than Jeff's so I'm not really
worrying about the aesthetics.
I'm worried about the sharpness.
[rock music playing]
All right, Brad, the one issue
I have about your handle right
here, it did cause some issues
by rubbing against the thumb
right there.
But, more importantly,
it is a sharp blade
for slashing and thrusting.
It will kill.
Cool.
Jeff, you ready?
Let's do this.
[rock music playing]
Ooh.
All right, Jeff.
The little bit on the inside of
your basket hilt right there,
it did dig in into his knuckles.
But overall, it will kill.
- Thank you.
Good job.
All right, bladesmiths, next
up is the strength test.
Ben?
To test your schiavona's
basket and blade,
I'm gonna punch into
these terra cotta pots
and then chop into
these birch logs.
And remember, it's
not what happens
to the vase or the wood, it's
what happens to your blade.
Brad, you're up first.
Are you ready?
My schiavona is
definitely ready.
[rock music playing]
[pot breaking]
[chopping]
[laughing]
Well, Brad, once I started
chopping into that log,
it was just going
the whole time.
There is a tiny little
deformation right there,
it's pretty narrow.
You can hear it, you know?
[tapping sword]
All in all, it's sharp,
and it's a good chopper.
Nicely done.
- Thank you.
All right, Jeff, you're up.
You ready?
Let's do this.
[rock music playing]
[pot breaking]
[chopping]
Nice.
Well, Jeff, this is
a heck of a chopper.
It's got a lot of
forward weight,
it's a little bit on the
heavy side but not too much.
In general, and in total,
it held up very well.
Nice job.
- Thank you.
All right, gentlemen,
this is our sharpness test.
You slice the rope, releasing
the sandbag, then cut the bag.
What we wanna see are good,
clean cuts through the rope,
and clean cuts through the bag.
Brad, you're up first.
Are you ready?
- Ready.
[rock music playing]
[crashing]
[slicing]
[both laughing]
Wow.
Whoa.
OK, Brad.
On the cuts, passed through
the rope with no problem.
This blade has a beautiful edge.
A fine cutter, excellent.
Well done.
Thank you.
Jeff, you ready?
Let's get it on.
All right, let's do this.
[drums beating]
[crashing]
Wow.
All right, Jeff, what
I like about your blade
is its look, this
industrial look.
It's cool.
It didn't slice all
the way through the bag
but it cuts very cleanly.
Nicely done.
Thank you.
Brad, Jeff, you are both
extraordinary weaponsmiths,
but there can only be one
"Forged in Fire" champion.
[rock music playing]
Jeff, congratulations, you are
our newest "Forged in Fire"
champion.
Brad, unfortunately your
weapon did not make the cut.
Brad, this is probably the
most difficult hilt design
we have sent any of
our smiths home to do
and you both did
a really nice job.
We had to look at the
finest of details,
and that was that rolled edge
you took in the strength test.
And that's why we've
gotta send you home.
I did the best that I could
and I put every single bit
of effort into my blade.
I am just so close to
being the champion.